stéphane dubois bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france
on l'a vu à plus de quatre cent
cinquante trois mille emplois détruits
mais pas seulement à cause du kobe 19
d'après elle ce rapport oui j'en sais ce
qu'on voit bonjour aujourd'hui on a par
contre moi je m'insurge un petit peu
parce que l'on ce rapport c'est toujours
très intéressant mais on à l'institut
montaigne qui nous publie il n'y a pas
très longtemps un papier sur le
patriotisme et de l'économie nationale
alors les plans de relance que propose
institut montaigne en on a toujours
tendance est à dire chez les
econoclastes le jour et nous dirons
quelque chose de sensé c'est pas demain
la veille
mais aujourd'hui quand on voit on entend
le mot patriotisme ça veut dire qu'en
gros on commence à nous parler de
suppression de rtt pour les plans de
relance on commence à nous parler de
travailler maintenant 11 heures et
bientôt pourquoi pas 14 pourquoi pas
ouvrir les camps de travail pour les
malades et pendant qu'on y est
aujourd'hui si vous regardez vraiment la
destruction d'emplois évidemment c'est
une catastrophe
les restaurateurs aujourd'hui c'est un
peu plus restaurateurs et hôteliers
c'est plus de 20000 hôtel c'est plus de
160000 restaurateurs si on parle de 30%
des restaurateurs qui dès qu'ils sont
totalement qui disparaissent à ce moment
là qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est plus de
lui pour son du pib' le souci ce ne sera
pas le plan de relance c'est pas faire
travailler des gens beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus pour qu'ils
gagnent beaucoup moins
je rappelle aussi à ces personnes là que
quelqu'un qui ne part plus en vacances
ne consomme plus donc le secteur du
tourisme
on en parle le plus voyez alors la
consommation des ménages va directement
à être impactée par cette crise ducobu
19 est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à une
inflation immense des prix après cette
crise
l'inflation des prix vous pourrez pas la
connaître aujourd'hui il fallait vous
avez aujourd'hui le problème majeur que
vous pouvez rencontrer aujourd'hui c'est
pas la question de savoir si l'état
s'ouvre ont peu ou pas payer sa dette
s'est pas c'est pas ça le débat
le vrai débat puisque aujourd'hui au
sens propre législatif et monétaires un
état c'est toujours en capacité de payer
le quid de la vraie question c'est
quelle est la confiance qu'on va avoir
dans les billets de banque qu'on imprime
et en fin de compte dans l'économie et
quelque part dans notre représentativité
au prenez le japon je me prends souvent
chez les econoclastes le japon c'est
250% dette sur son pipe
et c'est une banque centrale avec 110 %
de dette donc aujourd'hui on va arriver
avec ses fameux plan de relance à 115%
je ne vous dis pas que c'est pas grave
si c'est grave mais cette gestion est
pas juste duo kobe tu sais les 50
dernières années que l'on a de gestion
des atrides d instrumentalisation du
pays
donc la réalité inflation l'inflation
forcément inflation regardez aujourd'hui
vous allez dans n'importe quel mode up
dans paris faire vos courses votre
barquette de fraises à vos 5 euros 50
forcément l'inflation est déjà là mais
les luttes paysannes et demi il voyait
alors autre point abordé par le rapport
à l'intérim qui est le plus touché 300
mille postes supprimés soit une baisse
de 37% qu'est ce que ça a dit de notre
système économique selon vous le système
économique aujourd'hui imaginez vous que
vous avez des personnes en intérim
évidemment en fin de compte si vous
regardez bien on n'est pas dans un choc
pour moi ce qui nous dérange aujourd'hui
pardon c'est l'aléa moral quelque part
c'est la moralité c'est comment on va
relancer ça on peut pas dire aujourd'hui
vous avez quoi comme comme information
les messages c'est en gros une députée
ps madame ball et puis maintenant
monsieur car elle de droite
il commence à dire on va taxer tous les
gens qui ont un peu d'epargne de l'autre
côté ir soir pas plus tard qu'hier on
commence à dire les personnes qui
détiennent un coffre dans une banque
vont être obligés de déclarer et avec
les valeurs dedans donc ça veut dire que
les personnes combien un petit peu de
pièces d'or à l'intérieur va falloir
faire très attention à vous les
assurances vie commence à vouloir taxer
évidemment notre système économique mais
le système économique je dirais très
vulgairement ou pardon je vais risque de
choquer mais une raison de la
désinstitutionnalisation c'est aussi le
particulier c'est aussi le faible
pouvoir d'achat c'est aussi la
rémunération des personnes puisque
aujourd'hui je le dis souvent en
rigolant à des amis une paire de
chaussures une d'une femme qu'elle a
envie d'acheter sympathique une grande
marque française que je citerai pas ses
mille euros c'est pas donné à tout le
monde donc on va chercher des chaussures
qui sont fabriqués à malines taïwan donc
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus aucune logique
vaut consommer des fruits et légumes qui
viennent d'espagne qui sont hors saison
qu'ils sont bourrés de pesticides et
vous continuez très mal faire
malheureusement le panier de la ménagère
moyen moyenne par dont le panier de
courses ils coupent de plus en plus cher
donc la réalité c'est que les gens qui
ont pas beaucoup d'argent se tourner
vers les produits de je dirais de
mauvaise qualité qui sont fabriqués
desforges de saison on fait importer de
la viande de n'importe où enfin il faut
que les gens se réveillent la cij
merci stéphane dubois d'avoir répondu à
nos questions le rappelle que vous êtes
économiste et membre des aides
econoclaste voilà merci